a former new jersey republican governor
chris christie
is uh the author of a new book it's one
of these kind of trash political books
and he was interviewed he did the media
rounds yesterday he was interviewed on
cnn he was interviewed a bunch of
different places but the most
interesting interview that chris
christie did was with nicole wallace on
msnbc i'm not some big nicole wallace
fan i think she often does interesting
interviews
and she
really made chris christie look as
stupid as the book appears to be
on the subject matter so let let me kind
of give you the backstory chris christie
former republican governor of new jersey
involved in that horrifying bridgegate
scandal where they shut down a lane of
the george washington bridge as a
political punishment
to the mayor of i don't remember what
jersey town fought something
uh over a political disagreement just a
disgusting disgusting thing
christy ran for the republican
nomination in 2016 slammed donald trump
really really hard and then eventually
fell in line and was famously pictured
uh standing behind trump looking ill
like he had some bad clams as he was now
endorsing trump and trump behaving as
trump always does in completely
embarrassing fashion and chris christie
looking ill and then he has tried to
kind of frame himself as okay i did
support trump but then i also have
concerns about
trying to play every side of the
republican party so now chris christie
writes this book he's going to tell the
republican party how to save itself the
book is called republican rescue saving
the party from truth deniers
conspiracy theorists
and the dangerous policies of joe biden
well the republican party needs to be
rescued from trump it's really not about
joe biden at all and i apologize i just
punched my microphone there so
it's just one of these garbage books
enough with all the infighting the truth
denying the wild conspiracy claims the
looking backward the refusal to focus on
the dangerous biden agenda here's chris
christie's urgent guide for recapturing
republican glory what and winning
elections again told with the
new jersey frankness and news breaking
insights that made the two-term two-term
governor
trump early endorser and presidential
candidate an indispensable voice it it's
just completely bonkers and one of the
things about the book
um and you can look at the
um
i wanted to pull up the table of
contents for you guys but i'm unable to
right now um one of the things about the
book is it sort of seems to miss number
one like the main source of right wing
conspiracies which is right wing media
including fox news and these other
networks he talks about cnn he talks
about you know all these other
news networks doesn't talk about fox
news and good for her nicole wallace
calls him out and it's painful in the
best of ways to see how just silly chris
christie looks take a look at this you
know the book is called um it's about
conspiracies and lies and you really
don't take on fox news why not
look because you've seen this no because
because the book no i i don't watch it
but the book are you aware of what he
does not really i don't pay a lot of
attention to it republican insider
chris christie has written a
comprehensive book meant to guide
republicans away from conspiracy
theories
and he claims not to know what tucker
carlson does now he may be lying he may
be lying because he knows exactly what
tucker does he doesn't want to answer
for it that may be possible however
how can you even claim to be an
authoritative authoritative voice on
what republicans need to do to push back
against conspiracies and lies and say i
have no idea what happens on the tucker
carlson show but
truth deniers conspiracy theorists on
the cover right and you attack cnn and
the new york times and msnbc but excuse
me i don't attack them as conspiracy
theorists or truth deniers i talk about
bias it is more dangerous to the country
and then conspiracy theorists no but
that's the third section of the book
where i talk about the movement forward
in the center portion of the book we
talk about the conspiracy theories and
the truth denying that went on with
things like q and on pizzagate
the election situation john birch
society and that's what i talk about
there's two sections of the book and
you're kind of missing some of the major
stuff from the right i'm sure
accidentally you're conflating that i'm
not conflating them but i don't think i
don't think it's an intellectually
honest case to make against conspiracy
theories without taking on fox news well
i could listen then you can write that
in your book well i'm not trying to
rescue the republican party i understand
she's not claiming to be the
she's that's it's such a dumb thing for
him to say well put that in your book
she's not claiming to be the
authoritative voice about the lies and
the conspiracies that that have been
told that chris christie is whoever you
whenever you want to write yourself i
guess my question is you want to run for
president what's your relationship with
fox news well first of all i didn't say
i wanted to run for president you said
that so let's be clear about that well a
lot of people have said that last three
days you haven't corrected anybody well
i understand that i wouldn't open and
correct the record no what i've said is
that i certainly will think about it but
i won't make any decision for at least
another year do you think that fox news
in prime time is good for the country or
bad listen there are shows that i like
in fox news
and there's shows that i don't like like
there are shows that i like afraid to
question the purveyors of conspiracy
theories and by the way you're but
that's your opinion you're welcome to
your opinion like everybody else in this
country is welcome to your opinion i
don't consider people like sean hannity
or laura ingram uh purveyors i didn't
say either their names
so so
did you see what just happened
nicole wallace never mentioned uh
hannity and laura ingram chris christie
brought them up so you could say well
maybe he's got a guilty mind there
but
hannity and ingram are huge hannity was
giving medical advice on his show ingram
has been on an anti-vaxx tirade for six
months so not only did nicole wallace
not bring them up chris christie's lying
about they're not perfe they are
purveyors you said you said the evening
news programs at fox news 8 p.m hours
well and as i told you i don't watch the
show so i don't know what tucker does
from night to night um if i watch
anything at night in news because most
of the time i'm watching sports but if
you're watching anything in news i'm
usually watching either sean or laura so
you may or may not support donald trump
in 2024 you may or may not run for
president and a book about liars and
conspiracy theories doesn't have
anything to say about fox news
this isn't he's this is an expert he's
written a book guys
no the book talks about you continue to
conflate it and you know what i don't
know how you're talking about i don't
think conspiracy theorists without
talking about fox news i was a
republican i think they've done more
damage to the party than anything i'm
sure you do but if we want to go through
that i think there are liars and
conspiracy theorists on msnbc and on cnn
also so maybe i'll write a book about
all that but that's not what this book
is about
in that section of the book i'm talking
to republicans about the way i believe
we need to deal with media to be most
effective for winning
the conspiracy theorists and truth right
and he got two percent of the vote tires
which nobody else
on either side of the aisle is writing
about right now other than me no one
else is writing about that do you want
to solve them that's my question we've
done interviews with probably five to
ten experts on the they're people what
does that mean nobody else is writing
about it that it's it's
it's just an embarrassing interview
the proliferation of conspiracy theories
without dealing with fox news it's like
solving terrorism without dealing with
the terrorists well look that's your
opinion i disagree with your opinion and
i don't believe and i think it's
irresponsible nicole to analogize fox
news to terrorists
and of course you know
you can argue nicole wallace made a
mistake there with the analogy but it
it's act she's not saying fox news are
terrorists although you could argue that
there is stochastic terrorism being
carried out on fox news
but you could have used any analogy and
and and chris christie is able to not
deal with the substance of it by saying
you're saying fox news or like terror
it's like saying this is like dealing
with i don't know
but
it's it's it's like dealing with uh
with a flat tire
uh and having no uh way to pump it up i
don't know
there's a million different ways it
could have been set her analogy is a
good one i want to understand what your
solution is to the title of the book
it's about truth deniers and conspiracy
how do we purge the truth and ours and
conspiracy theories
yeah from our party and it's by telling
the truth to our voters to our voters
where do you do that right in my book no
but where do you go where do you go buy
it
chris christie is going to solve the
problem by giving a speech at the reagan
library without mentioning what's
happening on fox news so nice 99 nice
job by nicole wallace and the the whole
thing feels very grifty and she's right
that it does seem like a pretext to set
himself up to run for president which he
that's fine that he has every right to
do that
um but if that's the idea
we would imagine he's incentivized not
to go after fox news because he'll need
fox if he ultimately wants to run for
president so there's chris christie let
me know if you're going to be reading
his book uh i'm all set as i like to say
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at deepakman
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowls soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both i and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to splendid
spoon dot com slash pacman the link is
down below